[Applaudissements]
mon frère a perdu la vie en pourchassant
les demies
sa quête est aujourd'hui la plaine
[Musique]
accompagné moi
soyez à mes côtés
ce n'est ni le hasard
ni la destinée
notre rencontre est bien plus importante
que ça
[Musique]
chacun de nous
chacun d'entre nous
se doit de décider quel chemin emprunter
[Musique]
je ne suis pas le héros que vous
cherchez
qu'importe ce que vous avez pu faire
libérer vous de tout cela un jour tout
ceci sera ton royaume
ne choisissez pas le chemin de la peur
mais celui de la foi
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une chose qu'on sait faire
mieux que n'importe quelle créature de
la terre du milieu
c'est se soutenir les uns les autres
avec le coeur
encore plus grand que les pieds
nous allons surmonter cette épreuve
vous et moi
[Musique]
commandante attendait non nous devons
continuer
pourquoi continuez vous à vous battre il
y à une tempête pour moi
vous allez assez combattu galadriel
ranger votre épée
[Musique]
mais qui suis-je s'en occuper